today uh so my name is sandy maguire and
today i want to talk about um a project
i've been working on called wingman
and um
wingman is sort of my approach to make
programming less terrible
and i realize that's quite a charged
claim and hopefully i'll back it up a
little bit
this talk comes in sort of three parts
one is sort of the philosophy of why i
think things need to change and how that
could be different and that's sort of
just to motivate you so that um maybe
you'll be in the same headspace as i'm
in
um the second part is to sort of explore
what wingman is um in sort of the
discoverability mode and so sort of what
are the things it can do for you today
that will make your job easier
but don't really require sort of a
mental shift
and then finally the third part is to
talk about
sort of what tactic meta programming is
and how that can sort of really change
the way you approach programming and so
that's sort of where the um maybe the
clickbaity title comes from right
there's two sort of main problems i see
with with programming in haskell today
and one is that there's sort of this
fundamental tension between working at a
high level um and also
sort of at the lower level of sort of
syntactically doing it of like writing
the code we want to write and so
you sort of have to stay at this high
level of abstraction of keeping your eye
on the goal and saying you know what am
i trying to accomplish and what does
accomplishment look like and sort of how
will i get there strategically right
and then on the on the lower level sort
of there's the syntactic concerns and
it's sort of
being familiar with the language and the
grammar and the idioms in order to
articulate to yourself right so um so
the low-level stuff is sort of the
grammar and the rules and the high-level
stuff is sort of the poetry and like the
beautiful things that you like to
articulate
um and my claim is that these are
intention right because
every time you sort of need to switch
from the high level to the low level
it's a context shift and there's the
possibility that maybe we'll forget
right or we'll like
um you just sort of lose a little bit of
context and every time you lose context
i'm sure i don't have to tell anyone
like how much work it is to sort of
get back into the right head space of
being in problem-solving mode um i find
this often with uh with my partner where
um
it's fantastic to live with her because
i will sort of be down a rabbit hole
five hours deep where she'll come and
say what are you working on and i
realized like
i didn't know what i was working on
right i lost track of what i was trying
to accomplish i was just solving bug
after bug in sort of this tower like
this maybe tunnel of of implementation
details right without really any idea of
what i was working on
so
um
so i don't think this is a fundamental
flaw right and when we talk about
uh pair programming sort of that's a
that's a nice solution to this and if
you're unfamiliar with pair programming
the idea is you get two humans together
and they're both programs you sit them
beside each other and one is sort of the
driver who's responsible for for typing
code and turning ideas into code right
and they're sort of they can sort of
stay focused on the low level um like
linguistic abilities
and then their partner is in more of a
navigating role and if they have a
computer they're not using it to code
they're using it to like look at
documentation and sketch diagrams and
sort of keep track of what's the goal
and so by communicating between the two
they can communicate at a sort of a
mid-level abstraction and so it's not
too far for either party right
um and so my claim is that because
there's sort of fewer contact shifts
more work gets done even though you're
putting two people on doing one one task
right it seems to me like it's sort of
more than two times uh efficient
um
unfortunately we don't all have uh pair
programming partners right or in an
industry setting maybe there's just no
one we can work with and or on your own
for that for that case right
um and so so wingman to me is sort of
putting humans back in the navigator
spot right where
trying to to to empower them to say well
here's what i want to articulate and i'm
going to let the computer put in the
details and i'll show you a lot of
examples of what that looks like in a
minute
um
but there's sort of one other reason
that writing code sucks and
it's it's sort of inefficient in a
different way and the way i like to
think about this is let's say you're
writing a haskell expression right and
so at any given sort of point in time
there's only really three or four things
you might want to do right you might
want to use
some term that is in scope or you might
want to call a function
or maybe you want to do a pattern match
or you sort of maybe want to do a let
binding and that's sort of
everything there is in haskell right um
of course the details of those are the
the challenging part
um but there's really not that many
options at any given point in time
and so we can imagine maybe there's 100
things in scope maybe if it's a big
module right and so
um so maybe if we're generous let's say
there's 128
sort of options at any bim points time
there's sort of four fundamental options
and then there's sort of which function
will i call or which actual value will i
use right
um
and so if you if you think about 128
options that's seven bits of information
right sort of information theoretically
um and so
sort of if i if i were to take seven
binary yes or no choices i could pin
down a single message out of the space
of all possible actions i might want to
do
and when you when you think about it
like that seven bits is really not very
much right because there's also about
100 keys on the keyboard
which means there's also seven bits for
sort of every time i need to write a
character
and the inefficiency here comes from the
fact that if um
in order to accomplish any of these like
sort of fundamental tasks i'm trying to
do in haskell it requires more than one
keystroke right if i want to do a let
binding i need to write several uh
several characters even and so each one
of those characters is like seven or
eight bits depending on if you're ascii
or unicode right or plus
so i'm sort of doing more work than is
strictly necessary and um
if we can uh if we can turn on the the
slides uh we can
love to go from there and um
i don't think i have the ability to do
that oh they're on okay great so the
slides are on and
so
for example right let's say i want to
write the id function and this is sort
of my bread and butter i write this
function so many times
and so
i've sort of written the type here and
if you think about id there's um there's
actually only one implementation right
once i've written down the type there's
zero more bits of information because um
there's only one implementation and log
base two of zero of one is zero so
there's
there's no decision to be made here
anymore there's
excuse me the implementation is is
entirely defined from the type and so if
i have a hole here um the implementation
is sort of bind x and x and there's a
reason i'm using lambda syntax and
that's mostly just so i can sort of do a
word count
so this is 10 bytes
right of information in order to
articulate zero bytes of
code
um and so like why did i have to do that
much work right
um
you might think about this another way
and so sort of the wingman approach is
at every step of the way it sort of
gives you actions
um which let you sort of build the next
step and so these are implemented as
code actions in the haskell language
server so all of this is sort of
available today if you just install
haskell language server and you use a
code action
in visual studio code
the code action is sort of the little
light bulb that pops up when you get an
underline in vim i have to do some code
bindings and sort of it's the vim
approach always
but um so if i uh if i go like this i
can pull up my code actions so i've
written just a hole um and sort of
that's the paradigm that this is based
around is sort of whole driven
development
and it says i can choose by number now
right and i have four different options
here which sort of
again that's only two bits of
information right and um there's a few
of them but in particular what i'm
interested in right now is introduce
lambda so if i type two
um what wingman has done is it's gone
and it looked at the type of my hole and
it said oh the type of my hole is a
lambda
and so what i'm going to do is i'm going
to synthesize a lambda term
and i'm going to come up with names for
everything right so it picked a name
here x and then it moved it shuffled
this thing around just because it's sort
of more idiomatic to put our variables
on the left side of the equals rather
than to introduce a lambda
um and if i go back to my hole oops if i
go back to my hole
um oh i have to save i think if i go
back to my hole um
now i still only have four options
and one of them is attempt to fill hole
right because you can sort of imagine
i'm done now right there's no more work
to do to do so i can just say attempt to
fill a hole and wingman will implement
the function for me this is the only
thing sort of that will type check given
what's in scope
um and so
so it's sort of written this program for
me and again sort of
introducing the lambda was was
unnecessary
and i could have just done attempt to
fill a hole right uh type in number one
from the hole in it oh well actually
that's not a very good implementation so
that might be a bug there whoops
um so we'll just ignore that um
but
i think it did used to work i'll push
some code this morning that might have
broken some things so
um so let's let's sort of move on and
there's this fantastic function called
note from the errors package and it
takes an e and then a maybe a and it
produces an either e and a
right and the idea being here
you unpack the maybe if it's nothing you
have to give back the e if it's uh
adjust then you give back the a
um and so if i were to write this by
hand sort of i need to find e and then
bind m a
and then say well okay there's case m a
of and i have to sort of remember what
these constructors are
and then go like this and it's actually
more beautiful if i put the nothing
first and then in the nothing case
i could produce a left or a right right
but producing a write i know in advance
will not work
right it's not actually going to give me
what i want um because i don't have an
scope and so
as a programmer i could dive in there
but it's unlikely to sort of be fruitful
and intuition lets me know that
so instead i need to produce a left here
and now
um the only thing i can do is produce
this e right there there's no other
options i don't have an e in scope from
anywhere else and it's a scolum so i
can't produce one in any other way so it
has to be e
in the in the just case i do have some
wiggle room i could produce a left e
still right there's nothing stopping me
from that again other than sort of
intuition and knowledge that that's sort
of a stupid choice
and the reason that's a stupid choice is
because if i were to just produce left e
then this a is sort of unused and then
in that case the entire maybe is unused
and so that's sort of suggesting that
the type was a lie right
um but when you're sort of writing code
for people you sort of trust the user to
have told you the right thing
and so
wingman assumes that the user knows what
they're doing and that they gave uh this
argument for a reason
and so instead the the implementation
here is said to be right
and then once you've been going to write
of course the only option is to give
back the a
oh so that's sort of how you would write
this code by hand right
um
and now
so i guess actually before we do let's
sort of look at
how many code that's 93 characters of
code right times seven bits is what 700
bits of sort of work i needed to do
um that's that's crazy right in order
because again there's sort of two
implementations of this function and
only one of them is reasonable so
in the best case there's sort of two
implementations in the actual case
there's really only one implementation
and i still needed to expand sort of 700
bits of optimization pressure in order
to write that function
so let's again approach this with women
so i put down a hole and i can ask uh
i can ask for a
code action and i'd say i'm going to use
refine hold this time and refine hole is
like introduce lambda except it's sort
of a little cleverer and refine whole
will say use the only data constructor i
have where um lamp is count as a data
constructor
so sort of refinance strictly more
useful than introduce lambda
but a little less discoverable so again
this is written code for me and it's
picked two variable names right it's
picked e and it's picked m a where m as
a maybe a right it's not the world's
best name but naming things is really
hard right it's one of the two hardest
program problems in programming
and maybe more importantly because we're
in haskell we sort of don't have cash
invalidation as an issue and so it is
the only heart problem right for us
um so i can go back to this hole and now
i can say well now i want to keep split
on ma right this is a new option and
you'll notice i actually have several
more options here now
so wingman is sort of contextually smart
enough to say
what's the context in which i'm running
and sort of what are meaningful actions
to provide in that case you'll also
notice it's given me the option to uh to
use data constructors
of course my implementation doesn't want
a data constructor yet so what i do want
to do is case split on ma so i type 2
and i hit enter and um what it does is
you'll notice now it does a case split
right
what used to be one clause of m a is now
two clauses one for nothing and one for
just
and so this is quite an idiomatic thing
right where now it's produced
again it picked the name a for this for
this variable so
not only is this writing code for me
it's also sort of alleviating the need
for me to come up with names that don't
really matter right
i will admit um the names it comes up
with are not always beautiful but that's
the thing you can sort of solve
afterwards right you can get the code
writing written and then stylistically
change it a little bit but
so here um
so again i can sort of use constructor
left and then use e or i can just sort
of say attempt to fill a hole and
wingman is again smart enough to just
fill the hole for me
and likewise i can do that here on the
the just case
and i do it and it implements write a
but you'll also notice
that it got rid of the e here right
it replaced this e binding with a with a
wild card and the reason it can do that
is because um i've implemented the
entire function there's no more holes
remaining and so there's no more
opportunity to use e and then wingman
notices that it didn't use e
and therefore
it just disappears right and
by itself this isn't a huge feature
right but it probably saves five seconds
and it saves five seconds um every time
i do sort of a completion
right uh and my claim is that this this
time adds up not only does it add up
sort of um in the clock sense right in
terms of like how much time do i spend
programming but it also ends up
adds up in the time that i don't get
distracted from my main goal
so um
so that's quite exciting i find right
um
there's a
a few more things i might want to do and
we can delete this so let's say i have
some type foo which takes a boolean and
produces maybe a string i don't know
right i'm just winging it
so again i can sort of refine my hole
and um
so because there's always a code action
that will case split on any term that
exists
um
but maybe i want to keep split on sort
of a function application here right and
one thing i could do is sort of say like
i let x equals show of b
and then maybe pattern match on that and
then now i have a case split on x but
again i had to do sort of some work that
felt
like that was more for the computer's
case and for the computer sake than it
was for mine
so instead um what i can do wingman lets
me write an empty case statement and so
i can say case b of
and you'll notice uh on the right here
it says wingman complete paste
constructor's bool and so this is a code
lens
and um it's sort of if i uh if i type my
button that runs code lenses it will run
that and it'll sort of synthesize this
but if i go back i can say show b and
all of a sudden this bool turns to a
string now right and so now
um it's smart enough to say well okay
the types here are now a string and so
if i run that it gives me the string
constructors
so
i mean this is all like quite exciting
right um
but maybe it's not immediately clear to
you how valuable this is right if i'm
just saying okay left and right like
those are things that are so well
ingrained into my brain that maybe it's
not all that valuable to be able to
automate
but here's a here's an interesting case
right so let's say i have a size of hs
expert ghcps int
and you might be wondering what the heck
is an hs expert gcps and that is
ghc's internal representation of a
haskell expression
so um i just imported ghc there
automatically that's from the language
server not from wingman but it's a
fantastic feature
and you'll notice the language server is
also suggesting i i don't need to import
everything i could just import ghcps and
hs expert but um i do actually need
things so
um i'm going to refine my whole as
always
and now i can destruct on h e
and if i run destruct on h e wingman is
going to write a huge amount of code for
me
right this is something like 50
constructors here it's a really really
big data type
and not only did it write all this code
for me what it did is it went and looked
at all the data constructors
and then figured out the arity of each
data constructor and came up with a
a unique name maybe not a fantastic name
but
a name that correlates to the type in
some way
and then it wrote out every single case
for me
right
this is an incredible workflow
especially when working with ghc which
is a thing i do quite a lot in this
project
where
like can you imagine having to do this
by hand right because because this code
doesn't sort of exist in any place
there's the definition of the adt but
the syntax of that is so different
from uh like function application or
function definition syntax that um
there'd be quite a lot of like bite
mangling in order to turn that into this
so
i'd say this is saved probably five
minutes right here right and the amount
of code i've generated is like i don't
know how much do you think like 1500
bytes that's pretty good
there's one other thing i'd like to show
you while i'm here and um that is that i
can sort of do continuous case
destructing and so if i go to the hole
here you'll notice i have caseboard on
xv and gl and i don't know what either
these are but maybe let's uh let's do a
case but on gl
and what it did it was it replaced my my
function right my function clause it
used to be gl and now it's an lss of rn
um and so i can sort of continue and i
can say well now maybe i want to split
on ss
it's like oh hey like that split the
data construction again sort of inline
and in a very sort of idiomatic way
and then maybe in this case i want to
split rn and
again it sort of just continuously goes
out and builds and um and sort of
splices in and so this is a fantastic
way for exploring libraries that you're
not that familiar with right rather than
having to go through the haddock and
keep like checking what are the data
constructors you can just do it all in
your editor now
um
so i i love this uh
so there's one more thing i want to talk
about before i dive into the tactic
matter programming and that's um this is
an example i stole from edwin brady
who's talking about idris ii
and
in it he sort of implemented this h list
right and so if you're unfamiliar with
an h list it's a heterogeneous list
where a a list in haskell usually has
the same type in it right or always has
the same type so i might have a list of
booleans or a list of integers and a
list of integers may not contain any
booleans in it in fact it can't contain
anything that isn't an integer
but an h-list sort of solves this
problem um
when hls sort of uses this type level
machinery to say i know what is in sort
of what is the type at every index in
the list
and so i can write an h list i can say
my h list
um and so maybe i've got an h cons of
five and then h cons of true and then h
cons of hello and then h nil and so this
corresponds exactly with uh
the usual
sort of um list
syntax except instead of cons it's
called hcons and html
uh and so my list has what type right
it's a h actually uh well
language server will tell me on the
right here so i can sort of say uh add
the signature
and that is the signature of this thing
right so this is now a list where the
first thing is an integer the next thing
is a boolean and the third thing is a
character
and the the problem i would like to
solve is sort of how do i pull something
out of this right
in uh in the prelude for regular lists i
have this function which um
is called index of or something and it
takes an integer and then a list and it
gives you the element at that list but
it's not immediately clear um sort of
what is the type level equivalent of
this right i can't just make this be
h list
of something right because
there's no guarantees that this a
is the thing that i
have so the solution here is we write
this lmat data type and if you don't
really understand what's going on um
that's okay
[Music]
this is sort of a dependently typed
example we're not going to dive in too
deeply but
the idea sort of here is lmat is a proof
that the element at this number here
in this list is this type t
and the way it does it is not all that
important but you can think of this as a
proof that i know the type of this thing
so the function i can write is called
lmat right and it takes a pipe level
element
of some index and then the result type
and some types
and it takes an h list of those same
types and it gives me back the result
type
and so the way we can think about this
is if i have some list and i know
the element i want out of it i know what
type it is i can just give you back that
type
and if i were to implement this by hand
excuse me um the way i could do it is
sort of again sort of refine the whole
and then
i can do a destruct there's an option
called split all function arguments and
what this does is it does uh destruct on
every argument and scope that's bound by
the top level function
and so it's sort of nice if i want to
just iterate all of my my data
constructors at once
but hold on there's something
interesting going on here right i have
two arguments lmat and hlist
and they both have two data constructors
and so
distracting everything should give me a
cartesian product of the data
constructors and there should be four
clauses here but in fact there are only
two
right and is this a bug no this is not a
bug this is sort of um
this is like
dependently typed information that's
happening sort of that wingman is aware
of
and the way you can think about it is
lmat is a proof that something is inside
of this h list
right but h nil corresponds to an empty
h list and so there is nothing that can
be inside of it right
within within an empty list there is
nothing and so you can't get a proof
that you have something inside of it
and so wingman is actually smart enough
to say
there are no h nil cases here
if you have a proof of something then
then there is no empty case example and
um
like that's not a thing that's
immediately evident as a as a programmer
right ghc might tell you that if you're
if you're compiling it but
um as just like everyday programmer that
is not at all immediately evident and so
it's very cool that wingman will
sort of is familiar enough with type
level machinery that it can it can make
that judgment call for you
if i were to sort of go on and implement
this function um
doing it with my brain is quite a lot of
work but the interesting thing here as
edwin brady says is sort of um
why do i have to right
this sort of type level get it is the
program and now when or haskell just
wants me to sort of articulate at the
value level
but there's only one implementation of
it so why do i need to do that myself
so again let's um let's just sort of say
hey wingman can you solve this for me
again i'll just say attempt to fill hole
and it turns for a little bit
it's a little further
and
[Music]
there we go it's implemented this type
level function for me
so it's sort of familiar sort of with
enough machinery that like not only does
it identify that in this case t is the
result but also that it needs to do
recursion here right um
and so this is one of the primary things
that differentiates uh wingman from
other sort of code synthesis tools like
gin where gin cannot handle recursion
and it doesn't handle gadgets or sort of
any of the the haskell extensions so
it's uh it's quite an exciting
set of tools here
so all this is just to show that um
wingman can sort of write
uh dependently typed
uh programs right
which is very exciting to me so
um that's sort of all i have to say
about the code actions and now
the the remainder of the talk is to
think about sort of this new kind of
programming that i
alluded to
and there's a lot of times in haskell
that we that we write programs um but
there's no good way of of abstracting
over it right
and often we call these idioms
because
it's idiomatic but there's no way to
automate it it's a pattern that clearly
exists but it's unclear how we can use
the usual tools to automate these things
right of course there's always going to
be template haskell
but template haskell is quite wieldy and
it's got all sorts of weird performance
things and cross-compilation issues
and
um
and then also sort of template haskell
sort of requires buy-in from
from your team or something right like
if not everybody's on board to use
template haskell then it's going to be
quite hard to get through code review
um and
so
so that's sort of the motivation here
and the way we can sort of look at this
is to say i'm going to write a type here
and this is sort of a meaningless type
i'm just making something up here
uh maybe there's an estee a here
and maybe there's another data
constructor which is a list of
bars i know
this this type is meaningless it means
nothing i just wrote it um
and what i'm going to do here is i'm
going to write a functor instance for
this thing
uh something that haskell language
server will do for me is um it'll just
say add placeholders and then it sort of
adds all the function methods i need
um and that's nice because it it
pipelines very nicely with wingman um so
now i'm in fmap and so again i can sort
of refine my whole
and then i can um pattern match on foo
and now i can sort of fill in my
arguments and so fab of a
and now this is fab after fsa and then
this is map of f map of f i b on x zero
um
and so i'd like us to look at this right
and my claim is that this is
the functor instance
right this is the functor instance
and probably everyone agrees with me
right
and i'd like to believe people agree
with me not because i'm sandy maguire
but because they look at this and say
yes obviously this is the functor
instance right
and my question for you is how do you
know
right how are we so all how are we all
so familiar with the like the the how
are we confident that this is in fact
the function
and if you're sort of like deep in
literature you might say something about
you know there's a
theorem for free that comes here of sort
of given the type this is the only thing
we'll type check and i mean that's true
um but
i don't think that's what we're doing
right and if you're more categorically
minded you might think sort of to
yourself oh there's naturality involved
here
right and the naturality sort of um says
well
there's rules of functions and if it
satisfies them all and that is also true
but my suspicion is that nobody in the
audience when they looked at this they
drew sort of the commuting diagram in
their head and chased the arrows and
said ah yes every way through the square
commutes like i don't think that's what
anyone's doing
and so it's nice that we have these
techniques but they're sort of more
um
they're more analytical than is what
happens or what feels like it's
happening we're programming right what
seems to be happening when we're
programming sort of something more um
there's a little more intuition going on
right it's a little more instinctive
um and so the way that my brain seems to
work for this at least is is more
pattern matching sort of mental pattern
matching rather than haskell pattern
matching
um
and so in my brain i sort of have a lot
of rules for what a functor instance
looks like and i have a bunch of rules
for what a function instance doesn't
look like
and i can sort of just run through both
those lists and i say well
you know this thing looks like a
function instance and it doesn't not
look like a function so probably is a
function that's right and the fact that
there's no type errors suggests that
yeah i mean there's only one way to
write a function instance uh you know
isomorphism and so
so it's probably right right if all of
my little heuristics uh pass then this
thing is probably a functor instance
um
and that's that's fine right but uh
but that just sort of changes the
question to what does a functor instance
look like
and it's not entirely clear right um
[Music]
so
we can think about what a functor is
right and a functor
takes a function from a to b and it
replaces all the a's
into b's using that function and it's
not allowed to do anything else
and that not doing anything else the
part is is naturality right but it's
also sort of more importantly a
syntactic operation right
we can think about that in terms of how
does it how does the code look
so one consequence of not doing anything
else is that
it's not allowed to change the data
constructor right if i'm f mapping over
something then if i'm only allowed to
change the a's then the data constructor
is not n a so i can't change the data
constructor therefore i've mapped fu to
foo and i've mapped bar
to bar
right
another thing that i'm not allowed to do
in a function is to sort of shuffle
around my arguments right and so that
means sort of if i unpack arguments i
have to pack them up in the same order
so it goes s a f s a and then s a f s a
and x zero again x zero right
um and then there's sort of
so those are sort of the high level
ideas
and then within the code um for every
hole if that type doesn't uh mention a
whatsoever i must just sort of give it
back as i found it right i'm not allowed
to change it in any way
however if a um if a hole does mention a
then if it is a i must apply fab
and if it isn't
a but does mention a then i sort of need
to fmap my way through it
and you might say hold on sandy this
thing is not an fmap
uh to it i would uh retort that yes it
is right um the the fmap instance or the
functor instance for arrow function
arrow is equal to dot and so these are
two equivalent programs
and so written like this it sort of
becomes a little more clear about what's
going on which is
whenever i have a type that
mentions a a term that mentions a and
it's type
what i can do is sort of apply fmap some
amount of times
and then sort of as many as i need to
make a type check and then i can just
produce
the value so
what's interesting about that is the
number of times i want to apply fmap
might be zero
right i don't actually need to apply f
map if if a is just this thing and so
so sort of that's my claim is that a
functor at least one that is built out
of composition of functions is exactly
this it sort of maps data constructions
data constructors it doesn't change the
order of the construct of the terms
inside the constructor
and then um
for every term that doesn't mention a
it's you just give it back and for every
term that does mention a you have to
play fmap some number of times
uh and then apply fab and then that
that's it right
so so that's sort of the the idea right
rather than just slamming this thing out
i i took some time to analyze it and to
think about like
not just how do i write this but sort of
more generally what am i trying to write
and so we can sort of write this
tactically
so if i run code action something you
might have noticed earlier is this uh
this fourth code action here use custom
tactic block and if i type that in it
builds a wingman tactic
um this thing is using template half
kill syntax but there's no template
haskell going on here it's just i needed
to find something in the ghc ast that
would let me type a string and still
type check and this was sort of the only
thing i found so
so don't don't worry it looks like
template haskell but it isn't it's just
a convenient way for me to write strings
so if i wanted to write a program here
the idea is a tactics program is sort of
a high level sort of abstract view of
the code i'm trying to write
and i can i can run these programs and
they will synthesize code for me so
um the way it looks is actually quite
imperative and so maybe the first thing
i want to do is call intros
and i can run this custom tactic and
running intros as we saw before is sort
of just equivalent to making a lambda
and binding the variables
you'll notice again that it picks two
names for me f a b and foo
and sometimes that's what you want but
sometimes it isn't and so if it isn't
what you want um you can explicitly give
names here after intros and that will
then um
use these names that i've given and so
they they happen in order and so now if
i run this program
all of a sudden what used to be f a b
and foo are now f and x
and so okay well that's fine um
but what i can do now is i can use a
comma operator and that allows me to to
run a subsequent tactic after i did the
first one and so now the subsequent
tactic will work on the next hole
so the next hole i have um
is just i want to destruct x right and
so if i run this now
i've destructed x
right now i i've done a pattern match
onto phu and bar
so it's sort of quite a lot of work to
go back and forth and always be saying
well you know run the code unrun the
code and so one thing i can do in
wingman is i can do use my hover action
in the language server and for vim i
have that bound to some key on vs code
you can just use your mouse cursor hover
over the squiggly line and when i do
that i get this little pop-up on the
bottom
i have two goals right those correspond
to the two cases i need to fill in and
they both have type foo sb
but above that line is sort of what i
have in scope in order to to implement
that
and so what i have in scope for both of
them is an f and then what i have in
scope otherwise is the terms that i
unpacked
and so wingman is sort of smart enough
to keep track of like i'm synthesizing
code and i'm in different branches and
those different branches know different
things and so i can just say hey um
this is sort of a quicker way often to
look at the state of your of your tactic
um
so what's the next thing i want to do so
uh the next thing i think i want to do
is use a constructor to say foo right so
if i'm unpacking foo i need to repack
foo and so if i run this now again i've
produced a foo term and i've now made
three new holes corresponding to each
each sort of argument to the food
constructor
the next thing i want to do is sort of
say well i have an s and s doesn't
mention a so i just want to give it back
right
there's an assumption tactic and that
says just take anything that's in scope
that has the right type and put it there
which sounds a little crazy but as
you'll notice it does in fact produce
the foo ass
but hold on you might think like that's
crazy sandy what if you have another
essence scope how does it know which one
to use
um so fundamentally there here there is
quite a lot of non-determinism
and my claim is that it doesn't really
and the reason it doesn't really matter
is the way that wingman works is it will
actually synthesize every sort of
solution of the non-deterministic set
and then it scores them based on a bunch
of sort of heuristics that correspond
very well to what humans find to be the
right code
um i'm not saying it's perfect but i'm
saying it does a very good job and
almost never does this um
does this sort of non-determinism bite
you
so
anyway uh so i've undone my s change and
i've done assumption and so
what's the next call i have the next
hole i have is a b that i want to
produce and i don't have a b in scope so
i can't run assumption
and let's just try to run assumption
just to do it right if i try to run
assumption here it says oh wingman
couldn't find a solution and that's
because there was no b in scope to stick
in
so instead
i have a b and i want to apply f
right f is going to produce a b and so i
can use um the apply tactic and apply
takes a function
name so i can say apply f and if i run
this
now all of a sudden it says hey
uh i've produced f and it left another
hole for the argument and so you can
sort of see the the idea here right is
each time along the way you say i have a
tactic it's going to fill in this part
and it might produce more holes that
i'll need to fill in those those holes
get filled sequentially
something i can also do if i don't care
about applying f in particular i could
say application which is sort of the
same as assumption that says pick any
function in scope that will type check
and then run that and so if i do that
again i get f
um and so you can sort of now so now i
need an a right to as the argument to f
and so i can again say assumption and
you'll notice this isn't a different
assumption here this assumption is that
type s and this assumption is a type a
and ringman just knows how to do it
so i'm sort of now
i've moved from a level of thinking
about sort of syntactically what i'm
doing to sort of
a little higher level talking about um i
don't really care the actual specifics
i'm just going to write code and it's
going to sort of suggest things but
there's a bit of a flaw here isn't there
and that flaw is if you look at the
implementation of fmap it's already
quite shorter it's like quite a bit
shorter than this program i've written
um and furthermore this program i'm
writing seems to be sort of no better it
seems in fact it sort of seems worse
right it feels like i'm just writing um
haskell now but with sort of bad
imperative syntax
and that is true
i am writing haskell with bad impairment
of syntax and this is mostly just to get
to give you a sense of sort of how
tactics work and what are they um i'm
not saying this is a tactic program you
should write
so
the
if we wanted to write this sort of more
idiomatically tactically um the idea is
we want to sort of work at a higher
level of semantics
and if you remember my discussion about
what is a functure instance we talked
about sort of
um
we had this high level idea of you know
we have to map data constructors to data
constructors but then this code i wrote
sort of destructs x and then picks a
specific data constructor and so that's
sort of already moving away from the
high-level semantic idea that i wanted
to express and so i'm going to say we we
sort of took a wrong turn right at the
beginning
and what i want to do is not actually a
destruct right i don't want to do a
pattern match here i want to do sort of
a pattern match with some flavor and
that flavor i want to do is to match
every every
case to the same data constructor and so
that's not a destruct right destruct is
sort of lower level than that in fact
that's a homomorphic case split and so i
can use the homo
tactic here and what this does is i run
this now and it immediately produces the
data constructor on either side so it's
sort of
semantically closer to what i wanted
and once i have this
now rather than sort of filling in each
of these holes individually
remember again my analysis said um if a
type doesn't if a whole doesn't
represent uh a then we just give it back
otherwise we
implement fmaps and sort of the
implication there is that this is for
every hole
right
and so
um the tactics language gives me a way
to bind over every hole
and i say buying because implementing
this is a monad um
so i can use a semicolon instead of a
comma and the semicolon says i would
like to run the subsequent tactic at
every hole that exists
whereas comma says i would like to run
the tactic at the next hole that exists
and so
um so i can say semicolon and now i can
say sort of assumption right and so what
this would do is it would fill in every
hole with an assumption
but if i run this it doesn't work and
the reason it doesn't work is as we saw
earlier there is nothing in scope that
is b right and so assumption doesn't
work in that hole
and sort of the semantics here is that
every hole needs to succeed with uh with
the semicolon operation
and so because not every hole succeeds
here then
this bind doesn't work but
again my analysis suggested you know we
can either use an assumption or we can
do something else the nice thing about
the type of fmap is that both a and b
are scolums which means
there's sort of no way to get them right
and so if if i have type
if i have a hole that mentions b
there is no way to have an assumption of
that thing right because this thing
fundamentally just cannot exist just
based on the type system
so i need not sort of worry myself about
what if an assumption matches something
that it shouldn't because it can't
so the other thing i want to do is say
it's either an assumption or it's some
number of f maps
and in order to express some number of f
maps i can say with arg
and with arg is sort of this pattern
here where i can say foo is 5 and it's
like well actually i don't i want to
apply some function to 5 but i don't
know what that function is and so with
arg sort of makes two holes
and it makes the argument
happen sooner than the function
so with arg let me then the next thing i
fill in will be one and then two
so uh i can say i want to fill in the
next uh the next hole which is comma
right not semicolon because that fills
in every hole
and the thing i'd like to fill in here
is sort of the argument to fmap that i'm
fmapping over and so that thing is just
an assumption
so if i run the oh i don't think i want
to run this sometimes it'll be tempting
the demo gods
i don't want to do that so um so the
next thing i say is i want to apply some
number of fmaps in this hole i have
right and i could say um apply fmap
but i don't want to because that's only
one fmap and so what i actually want is
a nested fmap and so nested is a
combinator that will take a function and
apply it in its first argument sort of
as many times as necessary in order to
get something to type check
behind the scenes this is just using the
pipe operator
and synthesizing sort of every
possibility from 0 to 100
and then any of those which don't
subsequently type check just get
eliminated immediately and we don't
consider them
so finally
the expression i have sort of is will
look like this i've filled in x0 with
the first assumption and the nest fmap
has implemented this part and so now i
just have this hole left and so i can
here and now say assume f
and if i run this
all of a sudden is implemented fmap for
me
right um and i think it's probably
completely equivalent to this other one
yeah maybe modulus some some naming um
this is exactly the equivalent function
but what's what's really exciting here
oh and just like one last thing right
before i do this is i can't assume f but
i can also just use assumption because
assumption is also the only thing that
i'll type check here
and that works as well but maybe that's
being a little too clever and tempting
fate
so
so
the really interesting thing to notice
here is that nothing about this
definition mentions anything about foo
right i'm just saying operate on the
data constructors and then fill it in
with an assumption or f map
and what that means is i can now sort of
go back and change food willy-nilly i
can say uh maybe there's a zoo
in here and maybe that's uh an s
but maybe here i've got a maybe maybe i
don't know we'll put a maybe here we'll
say maybe a
we'll say
we can just we'll just change it like
crazy right
and so i've changed this type but i
haven't changed the tactic the tactic
remains exactly the same but if i run
this tactic
all of a sudden it now synthesizes the
new functor right an equivalent function
in a way that i didn't have to think
about
you'll notice that um
i used to have another instance down
here
in terms of sort of code written this is
roughly the same amount of code i think
if you look at it this is maybe 200
bytes and there's maybe 100 bytes of
code here
um and that sounds you know it's the
same order of magnitude but the nice
thing about this is i only needed to
write this once and
this implementation is sort of
good this tactic will work for any type
whose function instance is a composition
of functor instances
so it doesn't work if you have an either
with an a on the left side um because
there is no fmap instance for that
or at least fnap doesn't do what you
want in that case but
that's not a fundamental limitation
that's just you know if you were a
little more clever with how you wrote
this you could do that you could sort of
add another branch here saying what to
do maybe you could use a buy map or
something
um
so the idea is sort of i i only needed
to write this program once
sort of ever
and i also didn't need to have written
it in the sense of
this works for anyone and so someone
else could have written this this tactic
for me and they could have solved this
problem and if you know if if there were
sort of a tactics library somewhere i
could just pull that in and now anytime
i ever needed to write a functor i don't
need to i can just say well someone
solved this problem for me
um
like that that's really exciting to me
right the idea that
this is now sort of a solved problem for
everyone forever
um and i know you're thinking you're
thinking sandy you idiot obviously right
there's already a solved problem for
everyone forever and jesus you can do
that today but what ghc can't do today
is sort of semi-groups and monoids right
so let's say i have a data type called
zoop and maybe zoop is a sum of integers
and it's a string and it's an annie
right
i need to import these and again i can
just do that from the language server
and sort of everyone know what these
instances look like right um the
composition or sort of the the monoid
over
the product is the product over the
monoid
um and so i can say you add some
placeholders
and some
placeholders um refine the hole
you can say destruct everything
and now if i need to write this i mean
it's so much work right
why do i have to do this this is
terrible
and then the the monoliths are sort of
even stupider it's sort of a zoom i
don't know where zuper came from empty
empty from empty where these should be
have been empty all along so these uh
these are instances i'm sure sort of
everyone has written a million times
right you just you push the the monoi
and the semi group through the data
constructor
and if if my colleague were to ask
saying like sandy what is the semi-group
instance for zoop i'd say it's a
homomorphism
and they'd say oh cool thank you i
understand now right
and so why can't i just tell the
computer that it's a homomorphism why do
i have to go through the work of like ex
articulating the homomorphism-ness
of this
so this is another good opportunity for
um for a tactic and so we'll do the the
model cases first because it's sort of
easier
um and so what i want to do is produce a
data constructor and then fill in
everything with mempty
the way i can produce a data constructor
is with the split tactic which is a bit
terribly named i will admit um it sounds
like it should do a pattern match but
split sort of takes a product
uh goal and it turns it into
a goal of product and it turns it into a
product of goals and so the idea is sort
of
this thing takes one and it will split
it into all the pieces you need so
essentially this thing creates a data
constructor so if i run this it creates
a data constructor
and then i just say use mempty and now
that implements memphi for me
in order to do the other one
um again sort of i need to as sort of
always i'm going to make some some new
lines here
as always i sort of need to bind my
variables
and then i can say destruct all and as
you might expect that does the pattern
match for me
and now right so now i need to again
make it a data constructor so i can use
split again and then at every hole i can
say use append
and let's try that right and so what
have that done is it's just implemented
an append everywhere
and it's left holes for me
and you might expect me to just say now
assumption
and that is sort of
correct but not quite um and the issue
here is oh did i keep my instance
there's sort of a constraint i hadn't
mentioned and that constraint is that
the left side of every mapend
must come from the first argument
right otherwise it's not really this
homomorphic structure that we're looking
for and the right side of everyone must
come from the second argument
hopefully i can go back and yes
um and so
i sort of want a way to restrict the the
capability like sort of what i know
about for my assumption
and the way i can do that is using the
pointwise uh tactic combinator and so
what this does is it says um hey you use
this tactic and figure out all the holes
it produces and then it's going to zip
the holes it produced against
the top level argument and says the
first hole is only allowed to use terms
that are derived from the first uh first
argument and likewise the second from
the second argument
and so now this function i claim does
what i want a tactic and as you see it
just sort of implements everything we
wanted
again this is uh this is sort of
delightful right i've solved the problem
once and for all
um and also
what's particularly gnarly here is that
um let's say i have an endo on integers
and maybe a set of characters try to
import set
is the amount of code input to implement
these functions is linear in the number
of arguments
if i this code here is linear
in the number of arguments to zoop um
but the tactic doesn't change sizes the
tactic is the constant size and you can
sort of really see the value of the
semicolon of just doing the same thing
at every hole
um so i have one final example to show
you oh actually um before i do um again
this is sort of too much work
and what we could have just done is
written auto
and that does exactly the same thing um
behind the scenes it's auto is just
running exactly this program i just sort
of got bored of having to write it every
time
auto it turns out is the exact same
thing as running attempt to fill code
attempt to fill
so those are one of the same which means
you can sort of use the smart like
figure anything out tactic from within
tactics themselves
um so there's one final uh example i'd
like to show you and that is um sort of
everything i've shown you so far has
been well it's like a it's an instance
maybe wingman's only useful for
instances but no that's not true um one
thing we often like to do in high school
is to write sort of like little
languages and so maybe i've got an ast
right and so this thing corresponds to
some sort of type checked program
um where maybe i got in literals
and it takes an integer and gives me an
ast of int
and maybe i've got a bool literal
and maybe i've got an if statement right
and so if takes an ast that's a bool and
then an ast of an a
two of those and it gives me back sort
of whichever one right if it's true it
gives me the left one because my false
gives you the right one
um and we'll say i guess we also have an
equals term so we can say eek of a and
if we have two eeks then we can give
back an ac of bool right
and so this is like a we can write a
term here and then anything that type
checks in haskell we'll type check in
this little language i've written and
the way you often see this is you say
well i've written this ast and so
there's always this function that is
called eval right and it says if i have
an ast of booleans i would like to
produce a boolean right because this a
sort of corresponds to the type that i
want to produce eventually at the end of
this program
so if i were to write this by hand right
i can refine and then destruct and you
sort of it's always the same right
uh i'm gonna do some quick renaming here
ast-1
st2
this is ast3
i can say well if eval ast1
then eval ast2 otherwise eval aft3 right
and then in this case i can say valley
st1 is equal to eval ast2
oh and i have to delete this
that fine are you happy i might have to
restart the longer server sometimes it
gets a little drunk
um so this is a sort of a program right
and it's it's a common pattern i'm using
agata here just for the challenge but
anytime you write a fold it sort of has
the same structure
um
so
there's quite a lot of challenges here
and you might not immediately see how to
write this thing tactically and i didn't
for the longest time
either
some of the challenges are we have this
a thing that's a get it right and in the
first branch a is an integer but in the
second branch it's a boolean so age sort
of changes types as we go through right
we also have um some recursive bits on
inductive parts of the data type and
then sort of each code path looks quite
different from one another
but the question is sort of how do i
write this tactically right
um
and the first step in sort of
to do this requires a bit of a mental
shift right to ask yourself what is it
i'm trying to write rather than how do i
write it and so what is it i'm trying to
write is sort of actually it's more of a
fold right
and so if i were to write this a little
differently i could say well
let's say i've got ast-1 result is equal
to eval ast-1
and so i can sort of put all my
recursive bits in one place
and then i can
sort of
implement the rest in terms of those
right
r and r and r
what did i just do ast-1
um i can do the sort of same thing here
on the bottom line right
in
and then uh this
quite a lot of work to to do all this
and i can sort of do the same thing for
these ones right these ones don't
actually have any recursive bindings but
this is completely valid haskell and it
sort of makes it clear that there is no
recursive um calls here
so this is a little closer it's a little
easier to see the structure here right
um
and
and now sort of the only question here
is
where do we go from this one right
and the idea now is if you look at the
ins it's sort of just a function over
what's ever in scope now right
and this thing isn't really an if then
else it's actually the function if then
else
right
uh and that isn't in scope so we can
just go and define that really quickly
oh
um and so now it's sort of quite clear
what the pattern is right the pattern is
um we're going to sort of recursively
call all of our inductive pieces and
then we're going to run a function over
every all the work that we did and if we
didn't do any work we'll just sort of
give back the one we had
so let's write this thing tactically
um
so again we can sort of use custom
tactic block and i don't even need to do
multi-line here because this is such uh
this one's really easy so as always i
need to intro
and then i'm going to i need to destruct
right but it's not a destruct again it's
sort of something
higher level and it's not a homomorphism
because i'm not producing an ast at the
end of the day what this thing is is a
catamorphism right and a catamorphism
sort of comes from the same root word as
uh
catastrophe or cataclysm of sort of like
tearing down
um so this thing is a cata on x
and just doing this
you'll see will actually do all that
recursive shuffling for me and it just
leaves holes behind
oh and it's also smart enough to not do
this sort of stupid let like empty let
binding
but conceptually that's the work it's
doing um and then at every hole what we
would just need to do is say collapse
and collapse we'll take everything
that's in scope that seems relevant and
uh run it as a function argument and so
if we do that all of a sudden you'll
notice it's filled in n and b right
because those were the only thing in
scope that was relevant and they type
check so you might as well just stick
them in
and otherwise uh it's left holes and
these holes are sort of the only
interesting parts of the computation
right uh so i can just go and i can fill
in these holes and say well that one's
this and this is if then else
that's the whole program
right again um
this is like the most common pattern
i've run into actually so far in wingman
is is folds like this and it took a
little thinking uh and huge shout outs
to top woof for giving me uh for like
walking me through sort of what are the
pieces i need so
um
as always i can sort of add new
constructors here
string lit and you know i can add a
substring operation or whatever and the
tactic just adapts and it does the right
thing and so
um i'm running out of time
so there's a few just sort of wrapping
up things i'd like to discuss then i'll
open up for questions
um
but
sort of there's a bit of a call for
action here and
the call is sort of the hardest thing
right now is not engineering but it's
sort of the conceptual workload
and
i would love to sort of get more people
trying this because
really all the only thing that we need
right now is more people thinking about
it and thinking about what's the right
approach and sort of what are the
building blocks i need um
the machinery behind all this is is like
extremely flexible and um if you if you
sort of need a new base tactic one that
doesn't exist yet the turnaround for
that is probably on the order of hours
um so we can iterate really fast um so i
love to to just get people trying this
and trying to write tactics
and sort of thinking through like what
sorts of problems can we solve if we
think about them in a different way and
what sorts of problems can't we solve
with the existing bits and please file
bugs for those sorts of things
so with that i'm going to leave you um
i've got some links here these are some
resources um
there's a there's a reference here for
all of the commands you might run on
running tactics it's quite comprehensive
it's got examples for every tactic that
exists and i keep it up to date
and it's all computer generated as well
so it's not going to get out of date
and i guess there's a bit of a plea here
as well which is um i've got a patreon
for this this has sort of been my the
only thing i've been working on for the
last year i'm unemployed intentionally
just because i think open source is a
fantastic thing to be to be doing um and
i think there's a lot of like good value
here
um unfortunately it's sort of not
financially viable um today and
i would love it to be i'm not trying to
get rich off of this i'm just trying to
pay rent and so
um so if you've been inspired by this
today and sort of if this is the
direction you think the world shouldn't
be moving in um if you consider donating
like five euros a month like if everyone
did that uh who's watching this talk
that would like profoundly change my
financial situation to be able to work
on this um and if not i'll still love
you and i
this community is fantastic and means
everything to me so please don't if you
can't but um do consider if you can i
really encourage that so uh without with
without that i'd love to open up for
questions and see
um
be able to answer anything people are
wondering about